two straight games now with without a
pick you didn't have that happen all
last year is there anything that goes to
what you've done this offseason so
far what about the year before that or
the year before that or the year before
that uh you know last year is last year
um and it's something you know I've left
and you know the interceptions all that
it's it's I guess when you lead the
league it'll never go away um but as I
stated last year uh every one of them
has their has their their
story um but that's not where my mind is
it's not something I think about um just
being candid I really don't care about
the questions about him at this point